>>> THE DETAILED JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT SEARCH WARRANT
INCLUDED THIS EYE POPPING
PHOTOGRAPH SHOWING THEY MOST
CERTAINLY HAD NOT ALL BEEN
RETURNED TO THE GOVERNMENT.
ONCE AGAIN, CHOOSING TIME FOR
REPUBLICANS.
THE REPUBLICAN CONGRESSWOMAN LIZ
CHENEY SEES QUOTE YET MORE
INDEFENSIBLE CONDUCT BY THE
FORMER PRESIDENT BUT REPUBLICANS
ON THE HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
LED BY JIM JORDAN WANT YOU TO
IGNORE THOSE DOCUMENTS THAT
BELONG UNDER GOVERNMENT LOCK AND
KEY TWEETING THAT "TIME
MAGAZINE" COVER WAS A HUGE
THREAT TO NATIONAL SECURITY.
THIS IS SOUTH DAKOTA
REPUBLICAN'S GOVERNOR NOT
RAISING EYES AT TRUMP BUT THE
FBI.
>> YOU CAN SEE FOLDERS.
YOU CAN SEE BIG WORDS ON THE DO
WE KNOW THAT IS REALLY WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP BROUGHT TO HIS
HOME?
DO WE KNOW HE PUT THEM THERE?
DO WE KNOW WHAT'S INSIDE?
>> WITH ME NOW TO SHARE THE
REPORTING AND THEIR "WALL STREE
THE DAILY BEAST AND WASHINGTON
POST.
BIG WORDS.
SOME OF THOSE ARE JUST INITIALS
THAT TALK ABOUT HUMAN SOURCES
OVERSEAS IF THEY'RE UNDERMINED
COULD DO GRAVE HARM TO THEM
PERSONALLY AND TO U.S. NATIONAL
SECURITY BUT THERE ARE SOME
TRUMP REPUBLICANS WHO JUST WANT
TO SAY NO BIG DEAL.
>> I THINK THERE ARE A SHRINKING
NUMBER OF REPUBLICANS WHO ARE
WILLING TO SAY THIS IS NO BIG
DEAL AND COME OUT AND DEFEND THE
PRESIDENT.
JIM JORDAN IS ONE OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S STAUNCH'S ALLIES BUT
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS MORE WILLING
TO ENGAGE.
HE'S WANTING TO STAY AWAY FROM
IT AND NOT APPEAR POLITICAL AND
DIRECTED DOJ TO INVESTIGATE A
FORMER POTENTIAL POLITICAL
OPPONENT AND HE'S EVEN SPOKEN
PRETTY FORCEFULLY AT THIS POINT
ABOUT THE THREATS ON THE FBI AND
THE RHETORIC COMING FROM
REPUBLICANS LIKE JIM JORDAN AND
OTHER TRUMP ALLIES ATTACKING DOJ
AND FBI SAYS IT'S A WITCH HUNT
OR THERE IS NO THERE THERE.
>> IS THERE ANY RETHINK -- A
VERY IMPORTANT POINT A SHRINKING
NUMBER WHEN TO STEP UP AND SAY
THERE IS NO THERE THERE.
IF WE CAN PUT THAT PHOTO BACK ON
THE SCREEN.
JIM JORDAN WOULD BE THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
IN CHARGE OF LOOKING AT AND
REVIEWING THE EXECUTIVE ACTIONS
AND PASSING LAWS AND REVIEWING
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
HE WANTS YOU TO FOCUS ON THE FAR
RIGHT OF THE SCREEN A BOX FULL
OF "TIME MAGAZINE" COVERS.
ON THE FLOOR ARE SENSITIVE
DOCUMENTS THAT BELONG TO THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT, NOT
DONALD J. TRUMP.
IT NOT SERIOUS.
IF YOU WANT TO TRY TO FIND A WAY
TO DEFEND TRUMP, FINE.
IT NOT SERIOUS TO POINT TO THE
"TIME" COVER AND IGNORE THE MASS
OF THAT PHOTO.
>> THAT TWITTER HAS BEEN ONE
THAT'S SERVED OF MORE OF A
FUNCTION OF TROLLING AND ACTUAL
EVIDENCE GATHERING AND YOU HAVE
TO IMAGINE IF JIM JORDAN DOES
END UP LEADING THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, WILL BE
MORE FOCUSED ON THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AS THAT TENDS TO
BE WHEN THE OPPOSITE PARTY IS IN
CHARGE.
HOWEVER, THE THREATS THAT THE
FBI AND OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
ARE EXPERIENCING ARE REAL.
THEY'RE SERIOUS.
THEY'RE INTENSE.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY YOU SAW
SOME TRUMP ALLIES LIKE A LINDSEY
GRAHAM WHO DID BIDEN SORT OF
MENTIONED YESTERDAY, NOT BY NAME
TRY TO BACKTRACK A LITTLE BIT BY
WHAT HE SAID.
IT WAS OUT THERE.
WHO KNOWS IF ANYBODY SAW THE
BACKTRACK.
THERE IS ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THIS
LANGUAGE ISN'T GOOD FOR THE
REPUBLICAN BRAND OF BEING FOR